let's learn a little bit about springs
so let's say i have a spring let me let
me draw the ground
so we know what's going on with the
spring so let me say this is the floor
that's the floor and i have a spring
it's along the floor
i'll use a thicker one just to show it
to spring let's see the spring looks
something like this
oops i'm still using the line tool
see the spring looks like this this is
my spring
my amazingly drawn spring let's say at
this end it's attached to a wall
that's a wall
and i know that and so this is the
spring when i don't have any force
acting on it this is just the natural
state of the spring
and we could call this
we could call this
you know where it just naturally rests
this tip of the spring
and let's say that when i were to apply
a force of i don't know 5 newtons
into the spring it looks something like
this let me draw redraw everything
so when i apply a force of 5 newtons
i'm going to redraw i'll draw the wall
and magenta now
when i apply a force of 5 newtons the
spring looks like this
i'm still using the wrong tool
it compresses right we're all familiar
this we sit on a bed every day or a sofa
so let's say it compresses to here
and let me
whoops
okay so if this was
the normal resting so this is where the
spring was when i applied no force but
when i apply 5 newtons so i applied
5 newtons
in that direction
5 newtons let's say that this distance
right here is i don't know let's say
this was 10 meters
10 meters
and so a typical question that you'll
see and then we'll explain how to do it
is you know spring compresses or you
know elongates when you apply a certain
force uh by some distance how much will
it compress when you apply a different
force so my question is how much will it
compress when i apply 10 newton force
so your intuition that it'll compress
more is correct but is it you know is it
uh
linear to
to how much i compress it is it a square
of how much i compress it
well how does it relate
i think you probably could
guess it's actually worth an experiment
if
or you could just keep watching the
video
so let's say i apply a 10 newton force
what will the spring look like well
it'll it'll be more compressed
right let me draw my force
10 newtons
10 newtons and if this was the natural
place where the spring would rest what
is this distance
well it turns out that it is linear what
do i mean by linear well it means that
the more the force
it's equally proportional to how much
the spring will compress and actually
works the other way if you applied five
newtons in this direction to the right
you would have gone 10 newton 10 meters
in this direction so it goes whether
you're elongating the spring or
compressing the spring within some
reasonable tolerance if you we've all
had this experiment experience if you
compress something too much or you
stretch it too much it doesn't really go
back to where it was before but within
some reasonable tolerance it's
proportional so what does that mean
that means that the restoring force of
the spring the restoring force
of the spring
is
minus some number times the displacement
of the of the spring
so what does this mean so in this
example right here what was the
displacement of the spring well if we
take
positive x to the right and negative x
to the left the displacement of the
spring
was what the displacement in this
example right here x is equal to minus
10 right because i went 10 to the left
and so and
so it says that the rest
restorative force is going to be equal
to
the restorative force is equal going to
be equal to minus k
times
how much it's distorted times -10 so the
minuses cancel out so it equals 10k
what's the restorative force in this
example
well you might say it's 5 newtons just
because that's the only force i've drawn
here and and and you you would be
to some degree correct and actually
since we're doing positive and negative
and this 5 newton is to the n to the
left so into the negative x direction i
should actually call this minus 5
newtons and i should call this minus 10
unions because obviously these are
vectors and we're going to the left and
i picked the convention that to the left
means negative so what's the restorative
force well in this example and we assume
that k is a positive number
for our purposes
in this example the restorative force is
a positive number so what is the restore
force
so that's actually the force the
counteracting force of the spring that's
what this formula gives us
so if this spring is stationary when i
apply this 5 newton force that means
that there must be another
equal and opposite force that's positive
5 newtons right
if there weren't the spring would keep
compressing
and if the force was more than 5 newtons
the spring would go back this way
so the fact that i know that when i
apply 5 newton force to the left or a
negative 5 newton force the spring is no
longer moving it means that there must
be or no longer accelerating actually it
means that there must be an equal and
opposite force to the right and that's
the restorative force another way to
think about it is uh
if i were to let well
i won't go in there now so
in this case the rest of the force is 5
newtons so we can solve for k we could
say 5
is equal to 10
k
divide both sides by 10 you get k is
equal to one half
so now we can use that information to
figure out what is the
the displacement when i apply 10 a
negative 10 newton force when i push the
spring in 10
with 10 newtons in the leftward
direction so first of all what's the
restorative force here well if the
spring is is is no longer accelerating
in either direction
or this tip of the spring is no longer
accelerating in either direction
we know that the restorative force must
be counterbalancing this force that i'm
compressing with right the force that
the spring wants to expand back with is
10 newtons
positive 10 newtons right
and we know the spring constant this k
for this spring for this material
whatever it might be is one half so we
know the restorative force is equal to
one half
times
times the distance
right and the formula is minus k
right and then what is the restorative
force in this example well i said it's
10 newtons so we know that 10
newtons is equal to minus one-half x
and so what is x we'll multiply both
sides by minus one-half and you get
minus 20. i'm sorry multiply both sides
by minus 2 you get minus 20 is equal to
x
so it's minus 20 whoops minus 20. so x
goes to the left 20 units
so that's all that it's it's telling us
and this law is called hooke's law and
it's named after i'll read a physicist
in the 17th century a british physicist
and he figured out that the amount of
force necessary to keep a
a spring compressed is proportional to
how much you've compressed it and that's
all that this this formula says and that
negative number remember this formula
gives us the restorative force so it
says that the force is always in the
opposite direction of how much you
displace it so for example if you were
to displace
the spring in this direction if you were
to apply a force and x were a positive
and you were to
go in that direction the force
oh sorry this was where the right this
is where the spring rest if you were to
apply some force and take the spring out
to here
this negative number tells us that the
spring will essentially try to pull back
with the restorative force in the other
direction
so let's do one more problem and i think
this will be clear to you
so let's say i have a spring and and all
of these problems kind of
go along so let's say when i apply a
force of 2 newtons
so this is what i apply
when i apply a force of two newtons
well let's let's say this way let's say
when i stretch the spring
what am i doing let's say this is the
spring
and when i apply a force of two newtons
to the right
the spring gets stretched
oh i don't know let's say the spring
gets stretched one meter
so first of all let's figure out what k
is
so if the spring is stretched two
by one meter out here its restorative
force will be two newtons back this way
right so its restorative force is two
newtons will equal minus k times how
much i displaced it so i displaced it by
one meter
so then we get multiply both sides by
negative one and we get k is equal to
minus two so then we could use hook
squat to know
the
the equation for this
to figure out the rest of the force for
this
particular spring it would be minus 2x
and then i said well how much force
would i have to apply to distort this
spring by two meters well it's two times
two would be four
four newtons to to displace it by
two meters and of course the restorative
force will then be in the opposite
direction and that's where we get the
negative number anyway i've run out of
time i'll see you in the next video